justin is with us in Phoenix to start
off this hour hey Justin welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hey thanks pleasure to
talk to you you too sir what's up so I
think dug pretty deep hole and I'm
finally getting it to my bigger shovel
unity of this fall and that puts me in
baby step number two and by my
calculations it'll take about eight
years to pay off these big mountain of
ones using rice and beans which means
filling my retirement funding by about
eight years so I've been doing some
financial calculators and it seems like
that would cut my retirement on 1965 and
half essentially and if I followed the
repayment plan that would take obviously
longer pay back five hundred fifty
thousand more but I would double my
retirement on at age 65 so I love your
system and I want to follow it but I
need a little convincing on how to
follow the stuff seeing it has a bit of
a disadvantage it feels like okay and so
how much debt student loan debt do you
have
I'm about five fifty five hundred and
fifty thousand dollars yeah okay and so
what is your field of study medicine
I'll be a family practice doctor in the
fall be done with residency okay you'll
be practicing in what what part of
medicine family practice Family Practice
okay and pray tell why did it take five
hundred and fifty thousand dollars to be
an MD to do Family Practice a lot of
poor decisions most of it was advice
from other people early on in my career
that worried about loans it's just
another drop in the bucket everybody has
them and just takes like eat it when you
can and you'll pay it back later don't
worry about it so it was just this guy
did take him down too much probably
attendant because you're not yeah I mean
I was hoping you were gonna tell me you
were a neurosurgeon
but family practice what do you look
like a hot around and out at eight years
to finish that yeah what are you what
are you looking at Family Practice honor
and a half a year income 180 starting
okay and then going up from there right
okay and so why does it take eight years
if you're making a hundred and eighty
thousand because you could just kind of
like a squeak by on a tea and put a
hundred on and then be done in five
years yeah well after like taxes and
tightening and they found 110
essentially and then we are planning on
putting didn't the baby steps would be
about eighty five years leaving us
twenty to thirty to live off of okay I
think you did your tax calculation role
or something because it would seem like
I think we are able to get more than
thirty thousand I mean more than 80,000
on this but eighty thousand on it
doesn't take eight years either doesn't
just the interest rate that it looks
like it was over the next eight years is
a lot to about when your income doesn't
go up your income doesn't go up in your
scenario either it should yeah that's
what Hannah building in like a five
percent raise every year which is a
little bit maybe I'm the favorite aside
you know I'm thinking you're going to
get more raises than that hopefully and
is there other things you can do if
you're doing family practice I mean can
you work ER on the weekends or something
most places won't let you they don't
want you to come entire companies and
other shifts face on signed this and
won't let me there's other jobs around
hopefully that change if there's not
giving a little tiny I am hungry for and
I can use thousand more deals with them
but they said that they can come you to
work as much as I need and I build you
know because I mean you could probably
pick up another hundred a year working
er on the weekends yeah if you if you
can physically have the stem and
to do it I mean it's a lot of work and I
don't want it you know obvious um one
not getting proper care because of your
fatigue or something like that but all
I'm trying to do is just try to increase
the size of your shovel because what I
don't want to do I think you've run out
your worst-case scenario on every
possible scenario to get to eight years
and that's the only way your your
question even starts to make any sense
as if it's at eight years but but I
really am knowing that my point is that
I'm just not going to accept the eight
years I'm gonna go with a four year plan
a five year plan something like that and
yeah I am gonna delay retirement because
you this is a fast problem I mean this
is a patient that has come to you with
an extreme situation and and so the the
care the the plan for their care has to
be extreme and so and and yeah you
you've got to be extreme you're gonna
have to go crazy to clean up this
extreme mess and no I would not start
retirement yes I would get on beans and
rice rice and beans yes I would pick up
as much extra income as I can pick up
yes I'm gonna maximize my my MD
financially any way I can for a period
of time to you know clean up this mess
cuz you're just saddled with a an
unbelievable amount of debt it's just
hard to even fathom it but um but yeah
you've got to clean it up because you
just can't play with something like this
this is like I'm gonna have a you know a
you when you've got something stream you
have to react to it with it with extreme
and that's the only way to fight it and
so you've got to go bananas on this and
you've got to knock it out and it's got
to be a lot sooner than eight years
because I agree with you you're gonna
end up with less money at retirement if
you go with eight year plan but yeah
your plan just isn't right
the other possibility if you haven't
taken your job yet is is there a
a signing bonus with one of these
hospital companies that want you onboard
where they pick up part of your student
loan debt I've run into that several
times and I don't know whether there's
enough demand for family practice to do
that or not but I've had Doc's say you
know such as such a hospital will pay
two hundred thousand of my student loan
debt and I'm you know I'm agreeing to
work there for five years or whatever's
there but that's a signing bonus in a
very real sense and that's something to
look at too if you haven't already
landed your actual position is that
becomes that those kinds of benefit
packages or signing bonus packages in
your case is desperately needed so yeah
we've got to clean it up though Justin
you cannot drag this out and you guys
have just got to live on nothing and
you're going to be working a lot and all
of that is because of the decisions you
made up to this point as you said the
bad decisions